Reino Unido
Bueno vamos entonces a saludar a Daniela
Blandón Daniela bienvenida entonces a
nuestra mesa de trabajo en esta
transmisión digamos en directo que hemos
hecho para ustedes desde que se conoció
entonces que Richi hizo una pasa a
liderar Reino Unido siendo el Primer
Ministro de ese país Dani Entonces qué
se sabe del plan económico del que fuera
además ministro de finanzas en el
gobierno de Boris Johnson no hay
expectativa por supuesto en torno a todo
esto a qué va a pasar y cómo lo puede
hacer Regina que entonces repasemos lo
que le importa a los británicos en este
momento la economía Raúl pues miré en un
comunicado que había emitido El domingo
cuando anunció su candidatura Richi es
una dijo que el país se enfrentaba una
profunda crisis económica como ministro
de finanzas entre febrero de 2020 en
julio de 2022 en camino a Gran Bretaña a
tener su mayor fiscal desde la década de
1950 esto por supuesto como consecuencia
de la pandemia también planteó un mayor
gasto público pero al mismo tiempo
prometió más disciplina y reducir el
despilfarro de dinero durante la campaña
para la contienda en la que lo terminó
venciendo una criticó la agenda de
reducción de impuestos de su rival y
dijo que en cambio solamente los iba a
reducir una vez que la inflación
estuviera bajo control eso parece que no
va a pasar en el corto plazo porque ya
están en un 10% interanual de inflación
en ese momento cuando estaba enfrentado
con listros delineó un plan para reducir
el impuesto sobre la renta del 20% al
16%, pero en 2029 todavía no el ex
analista de goldman sacks también ha
respaldado la independencia del banco de
Inglaterra y destacó la importancia de
que la política del gobierno trabaje
junto con el Banco Central para
controlar la inflación y no para
exacerbarla puede estar un mensaje
también sobre tasas de interés que
sabemos que es un tema bastante álgido
están esperando alzas de tasas de
interés en Reino Unido bueno Daniela
vamos entonces a ver qué pasa en Reino
Unido con este pues nombran bueno no
nombramiento digamos ya cuando pues sin
rival digamos ascendió exactamente
registre en Reino Unido hablamos de
China la economía mejora en este país
pero el crecimiento Dani sigue siendo
débil Sí señor y eso es muy importante
porque recordemos china es el mayor
consumidor del mundo también es el mayor
el país que más entrega materias primas
la segunda economía más grande del
planeta se recuperó en el tercer
trimestre creció 3,9% interanual también
en comparación con el trimestre anterior
sin embargo sigue siendo el dato más
débil en décadas la demanda interna
disminuyó hacia el final del trimestre
debido a que un brote de casos de
coronavirus provocó bloqueos el
crecimiento de las exportaciones
aceleró en septiembre y las ventas
minoristas aumentaron menos de lo
esperado además el sector inmobiliario
que es clave se enfrió todavía más lo
que apunta a una recuperación bastante
tensa sin contar con que el desempleo
subió levemente al 5,5% con los jóvenes
experimentando una tasa muchísimo mayor
es hoy del
17,9%. todos estos datos iban a ser
publicados el 18 de octubre pero se
retrasó esta publicación para darla a
conocer una vez concluyera el congreso
del partido comunista el fin de semana
vamos entonces a ver los indicadores
Dani Comencemos en Londres si le parecen
donde el principal índice de la bolsa
del fusi 100 se recupera en más del 0,5%
tras conocerse que Richi es un Axel al
nuevo Primer Ministro la libra esterlina
se recuperaba en 0,15%. frente al Dólar
una vez se conoció esta noticia en
Estados Unidos las bolsas abrieron
mixtas una semana crucial en la que se
sabrá Cómo va evolucionando la economía
en los últimos meses y en Asia las
acciones de Hong Kong se descolgaron un
6,4%, a mínimos de 13 años el Joan
También cayó a su punto más débil en
casi 15 años es un día después del
cierre de este congreso del partido
comunista Y es que las acciones de los
gigantes tecnológicos y los
inmobiliarios se desplomaron hasta el
11%, Porque estos sectores son bastante
importantes para la economía y han
estado bajo una estricta regulación en
los últimos años digamos con las claves
de la semana Mira este jueves Estados
Unidos publica el primer cálculo de
producto interno bruto del tercer
trimestre del año después de confirmarse
que el país entró en recesión recesión
técnica al caer en el segundo trimestre
por segunda vez consecu ese día también
se va a conocer el más reciente dato de
desempleo de Brasil y el viernes el
banco de la República de Colombia toma
decisiones sobre tasas de interés esta
semana también presentan resultados
financieros grandes compañías como
Amazon Google Apple entre otras Dani
como siempre Muchísimas gracias por toda
la información económica nos vemos
mañana con más economía por supuesto
aquí en este espacio matinal directo
América vamos a conversar con más Romero
sala de salud Dani Muchísimas gracias
Nos vemos mañana nos vemos mañana
entonces y ahora sí vamos con salud